GRADY POWELL: Our undefeated
judge, Ben Abbott.
Ready to go.
[music playing]
[chopping sound]
Bring it on.
The khanda.
Hoo.
NARRATOR: The khanda is a
sword that gained popularity
in medieval India
during the Gupta
period between 320 and 550 AD.
The word khanda is
derived from the Sanskrit
word khan, meaning to break,
divide, cut, or destroy.
Its wide, thick, straight blade
was not only used for thrusting
but also as a hacking weapon.
When a Rajput warrior was
surrounded by the enemy,
he would pull out the
khanda and fight to the end
while swinging the
blade with both hands,
taking down as many
enemies as he could
in an honorable last stand.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Bladesmiths,
this is a kill test.
To test the lethality and
function of your weapon,
I will take your weapon and
deliver three vertical chops
and then a slice.
Ben, you're up.
You ready?
Guess so.
[chopping sound]
[music playing]
DOUG MARCAIDA: Well,
Ben, the damage
that your blade did cut about 6
inches deep into both shoulders
and right through the spine.
On the horizontal slice, pretty
much cut all the way through.
It's got a good feel.
This, sir, will kill.
- Thank you.
- Tom, it's your turn.
You ready?
I'm ready.
[chopping sound]
DOUG MARCAIDA: Tom,
you definitely cut
in about 6 inches deep on the
shoulders and about 8 inches
into the spinal column.
You cut halfway through
into the carcass.
Also feels good in balance with
the downward vertical slice.
There was a slight bend that's
happening to your blade,
but it will kill.
Bladesmiths, this is
the sharpness test.
I will slash across
these bungee cords.
If your blade is sharp, it
should cut all the way through.
If not, it may just push
it aside or bounce off.
Ben, you're up.
Are you ready?
Sure.
[music playing]
Shit.
Well, Ben, your
sword started to cut.
It cut a little bit, but
it did not cut through.
It feels good on the slice.
The handle is very
comfortable in the hand.
But once again, it
didn't cut through.
So it brings into
question the sharpness.
Tom, it's your turn.
Are you ready?
I'm ready.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Let's do this.
[music playing]
Ooh.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Well, Tom,
it did cut a little bit
into the bungee cord.
But then as you see, that
transference of energy
went all the way
back to the blade.
It wasn't sharp
enough to cut through,
and it bent your
blade, which brings
to question the heat treatment
you did on your blade.
Cut around corners, now.
It'll cut around
corners this time, right?
But this particular case,
it will not cut, sir.
Gentlemen, both
of your weapons
failed in the sharpness test.
Historically, in
battle, blades bend.
Tom, we'd like to give
you the opportunity
to straighten your
blade so that you
can continue with this fight.
However, we will be taking
that bend into consideration
when it comes to final judging.
I understand.
Should have left it thicker,
but I'm not a quitter.
I'm going to fight to the end.
[hammering]
OK, Tom, you've
straightened your blade.
We can continue with testing.
Dave.
DAVID BAKER: Gentlemen,
this is the strength test.
I'm going to take five chops
into these copper pipes
and see how far
through we can split.
Ben, are you ready?
Not at all.
Yes.
[pounding]
Wow.
Ben, it's still one
piece, but barely.
And the dimensions of your guard
here on my hand are perfect.
Your blade-- it's
held up beautifully.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
So Tom, your turn.
OK.
DAVID BAKER: All right.
[pounding]
So Tom, what happened is we
lost a piece of the guard
right there.
- Yeah.
DAVID BAKER: With the broken
guard and the bend earlier,
I feel it's unsafe to continue.
All right, thank you, Tom.
I'm disappointed.
I know I could do better.
But that's what happens when
you don't use your time right.
Gentlemen, in just
five days, you've
both done an amazing amount
of work on your khandas.
But in this arena, there can
only be one "Forged in Fire"
champion.
Ben, you are the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
Tom, unfortunately, your
weapon did not make the cut.
Please surrender your weapon.
Well, I got to meet
some real nice craftsmen.
And I learned, don't let
your age slow you down.
You don't know how long you got.
Ben, congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion
and will be receiving
a check for $10,000.
Good job.
Thank you.
DAVID BAKER: Most people
get guard sizes all wrong,
and the khanda has a
deceptively small guard.
You just hit it out of the park.
Thank you.
It feels amazing to be a
"Forged in Fire" champion.
It's a wonderful validation of
a long time of knife making.
And I made new friends.
I made $10,000.
What more could you ask for?
HOST: The Scottish claymore.
Claymore.
Yay.
Joy.
NARRATOR: This massive,
two-handed sword
was wielded by Scottish
Highlanders as early as 1490.
Made famous in
modern pop culture
by the film "Braveheart," its
impressive size and length
made it a fearsome weapon.
The claymore is easily
recognizable by its quatrefoil
crossguard and angled arms.
Due to its large size,
the heavy sword was
usually swung with two hands.
It was so deadly,
it was nicknamed
the slaughter sword
by the English who
faced it on the battlefield.
Because of its
prowess, the claymore
was a mainstay of the Scottish
army for nearly two centuries.
WIL WILLIS: First up
is the strength test.
As you can see, we've
brought back a test
worthy of a champion's blade--
bullet splitting.
Each of your blades will
be locked into a vise that
will fire a single round at
your blades to test their edge
retention and strength.
If your weapons are
strong, it should
split the bullet no problem.
If they're not strong,
well, your blade
could shatter entirely.
Good luck.
Matt, you're up first.
MATT PARKINSON: I'm feeling
pretty good about my sword.
It's exactly the same heat
shield I did last time,
and it held up perfectly fine.
[music playing]
WIL WILLIS: 3, 2, 1.
Engage.
[gunshot]
[bleep] yeah.
BEN ABBOTT: Nice.
You got a couple of little
dimples on the edge, there.
It's just a little
bit dulled, but
everything held up beautifully.
Good job, Matt.
MATT PARKINSON: Thank you.
Ben, you're up.
Are you ready?
- Sure.
Let's do it.
J. NIELSON: Let's get her ready.
3, 2, 1.
Engage.
[gunshot]
BEN ABBOTT: Nice.
MATT PARKINSON: There we go.
[applause]
DAVID BAKER: Yeah that
sucker just fragmented.
Well, Ben, the only
problem I could see
is it rubbed a little
bit of your etch off.
Did nothing at all to the blade.
Edge is still perfect.
Thank you.
J. NIELSON: All right, next
up is a sharpness test.
And I'm going to hand you
over to Dave for that.
Gentlemen, the Scottish
claymore, as you know,
was a brutal weapon
on the battlefield.
So to test the sharpness
of your blades,
I'm going to take a
single blow through both
these front legs of the horse,
simulated with sugar cane.
If your blades are sharp, they
should pass right through.
Matt, you're up.
Are you ready?
Yeah.
Kill the horse.
[music playing]
Matt, this weapon
is so amazingly light
and flexible, as well, that when
I hit, there was no resistance.
It literally passed
right through the legs.
I was through them
before I knew it.
Well done, Matt.
Really well done.
Ben, you ready?
- Let's do it.
DAVID BAKER: All right,
let's give it a try.
[cracking]
MATT PARKINSON: He's still down.
Yeah.
Well, Ben, it cut cleanly
through the first leg.
Kind of bogged down on the
second leg, unlike Matt's.
And I have a feeling it's
the width of the profile
up here just slowing
it down a bit.
But I don't think that
horse is running ever again.
Nicely done, Ben.
Thank you.
Next up is the kill test.
For that, I'm going to
hand you over to Doug.
Bladesmiths, this
is the kill test.
To see how lethal your blades
are, I will take your claymore,
and I will try to cut
through these pig carcasses
with one chop.
As you know last
season, both claymores
suffered catastrophic
failures on this very test.
Let's see how much lethal
damage your blades can do.
Matt, you're up first.
Are you ready?
Go for it.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Let's do this.
[slicing sound]
It didn't break.
That's the important part.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Matt, I love
the feel of your blade.
It feels very
comfortable in the hands.
It's very easy to maneuver.
It was sharp enough to cut
through in terms of lacerating,
but it's just so flexible,
it didn't go through.
For this test, sir,
it will not kill.
I'm pissed at
that pig right now.
Ben, you're up next.
You ready?
Hope so.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Let's do this.
[slicing sound]
Ben, this blade
just sliced all
the way through that carcass.
It's flexible.
It's got a good feel to the cut.
This, sir, will kill.
Thanks.
MATT PARKINSON: Good job.
All right, bladesmiths.
You've given the judges
a lot to talk about.
We're going to have to go back
to the forge and deliberate.
We'll see you there.
Thank you.
WIL WILLIS: Matt,
Ben, welcome back.
The judges have
evaluated your weapon's
performance and construction.
Both of your weapons are
bulletproof, they're sharp,
and they're deadly.
But today, there can only be
one "Forged in Fire" champion.
Ben, congratulations, you
are our first two-time
"Forged in Fire" champion.
Great job.
Matt, I have to ask
you to surrender
your Scottish claymore.
MATT PARKINSON: I'm a
"Forged in Fire" champion.
That's never going to go away.
I don't feel like
I failed in this.
I don't feel like I'm a
loser in this or anything.
I just feel like Ben
did slightly better,
and that's awesome.
WIL WILLIS: Ben,
you are our first
and only two-time "Forged
in Fire" champion.
You'll also be receiving
that check for $10,000.
DAVID BAKER: Your claymore
is a thing of beauty,
not only to look
at, but to wield.
- I'm at a loss for words.
- Thank you.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Beautiful job.
Oh, my god.
I am the "Forged in Fire"
champion of champions.
I can't believe it.
The people I was competing
against are so good.
To actually come out
and win this thing
is absolutely amazing.
HOST: The messer.
The messer traces its origins
back to 15th century Germany.
While these swords
range in size,
they are distinguished by the
intricate hilts and guards.
Back in season 6 of
"Forged in Fire,"
two smiths were tasked to
recreate the massive version
of this weapon, where the
competition ultimately
went to the lighter,
better-balanced blade.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Bladesmiths,
this is a dynamic kill test.
To find out how lethal
your weapons are,
I'm going to take your
swords, cut through the vines,
and deliver some lethal
blows on this pig carcass.
It's time to have fun.
[music playing]
[chopping sound]
All right, guys.
First up, the handle
construction--
it's a little bit
on the blocky side.
But it's comfortable.
Why?
Because it's light.
Every cut, every
one of them, was
very deep on this pig carcass.
Overall, this 8-hour
messer sword--
it will kill.
BEN ABBOTT: I'm pretty
confident that my sword
is not going to break.
But something might chip.
Something might roll.
Anything is possible.
I'm just nervous.
[chopping sound]
So right off the bat, I
really appreciate the flare
on a heavier blade
like this because it
does allow me to control it.
The weight of this
cuts very deep.
It thrusts nicely and
delivers on the way out.
A blade like this--
it will kill.
[music playing]
All right, gentlemen,
a little bit of history.
In 1570, Joachim
Meyer's treatise
on the use of the dussack
was published-- the training
manual for the messer.
So we know that
was used by peasant
soldiers as well as nobility.
So to that end, our
dynamic strength test.
Gentlemen, I'll be
taking your messers
and attacking our
armored warrior here.
After that, we'll
see what kind of edge
you have left by
slicing that painting.
You guys ready?
- Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
DAVID BAKER: OK.
[music playing]
[metal striking]
All right, so right off,
it's taken a couple of rolls
that I can feel with
the fingernail and then
a couple of small, minor chips.
But for hitting armor,
it's not so bad.
All in all, our gold
anvil did a good job.
[music playing]
[metal striking]
All right, so as far as the
edge goes, nothing's come off
and nothing's
really rolled over.
So all in all, I think the red
anvil did a really nice job.
GRADY POWELL: Now, guys,
the judges had a very
difficult decision to make.
And they came up
with a final decision
that they both agreed upon.
The winner of this "Forged
in Fire" competition
is Ben Abbott with
the red anvil.
Congratulations.
No way.
Now, Brandon, you absolutely
smoked this competition.
But unfortunately, your messer
didn't make the cut today,
and Dave Baker is
going to tell you why.
Brandon, you did a
great job on that messer.
It's fast, and it's deadly.
This basically came down to
damage and some design choices.
Fair enough.
GRADY POWELL: I
can honestly say,
you're one of the
most talented smiths
I've ever laid my eyes on.
Thank you.
GRADY POWELL: We appreciate
all of your hard work
in this competition,
but unfortunately,
I'm going to have
to ask you to please
step off the forge floor.
- Thank you for the time, guys.
- Thank you.
Good job, man.
Awesome work.
Thanks, Ben.
Today just wasn't
my day, but I think
I turned in an absolute
phenomenal blade
that stacked up against one
of the best, Ben Abbott.
GRADY POWELL: All right, Ben.
You did it.
Your messer took
home the win, again.
You're now 5 and 0, man.
Congratulations.
BEN ABBOTT: This was an
extremely close competition.
Brandon is a hell
of a competitor.
He made a really
good messer sword.
And I was actually practicing my
happy-faced concession speech.
You ready for more?
Yep.
Let's do it.
Any bladesmiths who
want to come in here
and challenge me in my own
house, I'm here, ready for you.
GRADY POWELL: The Irish,
ring-hilted sword.
Oh.
NARRATOR: The Irish
ring sword was
a weapon of the elite,
Gallowglass mercenaries
in 12th century Ireland.
This extremely long,
double-edged sword
was featured in season 5
of "Forged in Fire," where
the Smiths were challenged with
not only having to forge out
something of this length,
but also the added challenge
of putting a fuller in it.
While both smiths struggled
to make such a long blade
both light and strong, one smith
went too thin in his design,
causing a bend in testing and
costing him the competition.
DOUG MARCAIDA: All
right, bladesmiths.
Welcome to the
dynamic kill test.
To find out how lethal
your weapons are,
I'm going to deliver some deadly
blows on this ballistics dummy
and cut some water tubes.
[music playing]
[chopping sound]
All right, guys.
When delivering
the cuts over here,
they slash nicely
through the water tubes
and just demolish
that ballistics dummy.
On that piece, probably
ran out of blade
as I'm cutting on the backhand.
But as you can see, the
cuts, they are very sharp.
Overall, it will kill and cut.
I'd say so.
[music playing]
[chopping sound]
DOUG MARCAIDA: All right,
first up, when I pick this up,
you can tell there's a big
difference in the weight.
The edge is sharp.
So when I'm chopping into
the ballistics dummy,
it's a deep cut, but it's
heavier and harder to control.
It cut the first two tubes,
and then pushed the rest.
But overall, looking at the
damage to the ballistics dummy
and some of the
cuts, it will kill.
DAVID BAKER: All
right, gentlemen,
it's time for our
dynamic strength test--
the bamboo sword chop
and tatami mat slice.
I'm not only looking at
how well your weapons
hold up in this test
but how they feel
and how well they cut.
Silver is up first.
[music playing]
[striking sound]
All right, guys, right off, the
blade is really, really light.
The edges are really sharp.
All in all, I think this is
a really well-crafted sword.
Held up very nicely--
there's just no
damage on this edge.
[striking sound]
All right, right off,
this thing's a destroyer.
[laughter]
It's not outside the
realm of proper weight.
This is kind of
the outside edge.
When cutting, you feel
the blade slow down,
as opposed to just pass
through the tatami mat,
so it's got a lot of drag on it.
And that really has to do with
the thickness of the blade
and the style of the
grind that's on this edge.
But it held up
well and cut good.
Good job.
GRADY POWELL: All right,
bladesmiths, the time
has come to find
out if, Ben, you're
going to keep your
unbeaten streak going
or if, Rob, you've
dethroned the king
and you're taking home the
title of "Forged in Fire"
champion and a
check for $10,000.
I got to say, this
was a very close race,
and you made a difficult
decision for the judges.
Today's "Forged in
Fire" champion is--
[music playing]
--Ben Abbott.
Ben, congratulations.
You are now 6 and 0.
Now, Rob, you gave him an
unbelievable run for his money.
But unfortunately, your
blade didn't make the cut.
I'm going to have
to ask you to please
step off the forge floor.
- All right, well, thank you.
I had a great time.
HOST: Thank you so much.
HOST: Hey, Rob, nice
job on that blade.
Thank you.
I'm going to go
home, see my family,
and make a really nice
Irish ring-hilted sword.
And it's going to take me a
lot longer than just 9 hours.
GRADY POWELL: Well, Ben,
that's 6 and 0, buddy.
You are unbelievable.
You are, yet again, the
"Forged in Fire" champion.
Congratulations.
I can't believe it.
Rob is a great smith, a really
fun guy, a great competitor,
and I'm really happy to
have worked next to him.
GRADY POWELL: It looks
like you're keeping
the unbeaten streak alive.
Congratulations, man.
You're not done yet.
We got more to go.
I hope you're ready.
Oh, my god.
What did I sign up for?
Good job, bud.
[clapping]
For those that are coming to
try to beat me, I'm still here.
I'm still undefeated.
Bring it on.
HOST: The Chinese war sword.
Oh.
NARRATOR: The 17th
century Chinese war sword
was used in battle starting
in the Qing dynasty
through 20th century.
Primarily used by peasant
armies, this large,
two handed-weapon
fatally slashed
and chopped through more
than 3,000 Japanese forces
during World War II.
This deadly blade previously
appeared on season 7 of "Forged
in Fire," where both smiths
struggled with the weight
and size of this massive sword.
But in the end, one
smith's weapon fell victim
to the dreaded ice block.
DOUG MARCAIDA: All
right, bladesmiths--
two beautiful swords.
But now, it's time to find
out how lethal they are.
This is the dynamic kill test.
Shall we begin?
[chopping sound]
Holy cow.
All right, gents.
On this blue anvil weapon,
when you pick it up,
it's got that forward weight.
But being a two-handed sword,
it actually is comfortable.
Now, in terms of the edge,
well, pretty much demolished
this ballistics dummy.
Overall, it will kill.
Caleb's blade played
performed really well.
If my blade takes a bend
when Caleb's did not,
it's over for me.
[chopping sound]
DOUG MARCAIDA: All right,
guys, right off the bat,
it is a light weapon to wield.
The edge is very sharp.
And in every cut,
it was very deep.
Overall, this
weapon-- it will kill.
DAVID BAKER: All right,
gentlemen, it's time
for the dynamic strength test.
We've got bamboo and cane in
our bamboo forest over here.
Blue weapon is up first.
You both ready?
Let's do it.
[music playing]
[chopping sound]
DAVID BAKER: All right,
so the blue anvil sword--
it's a heavy piece, and
it's very forward-weighted.
Edge held up nice.
When I run my finger
down it, there's
one spot that I
can feel something,
but literally have to run
my fingernail down that edge
to feel it.
All in all, held up beautifully.
Can't complain.
[music playing]
[chopping sound]
All right, as far as the edge
goes, no damage whatsoever.
The decorative touches
are nice, but what
I really like about this
blade is its functionality.
All-around, good blade.
Really nicely done.
GRADY POWELL:
Bladesmiths, this has
been an awesome competition.
But the time has come for us
to find out if, Ben, you're
going to remain undefeated
or if, Caleb, you're
going to be first one
to take down the champ
and go home with the
title of "Forged in Fire"
champion and get a
check for $10,000.
Our judges had quite
the discussion,
but they came up with
a common decision.
The winner of today's "Forged
in Fire" competition is--
[music playing]
--Ben Abbott.
You have done it again.
Congratulations.
Caleb, you built a beautiful,
strong, and sharp blade.
But unfortunately, it
didn't make the cut today.
And Dave Baker is
going to tell you why.
DAVID BAKER: Ben's
blade with that
dragon and pattern
and the handle wrap
was just more impressive.
Absolutely.
Now, Caleb, it's been an
honor watching you work.
But unfortunately,
at this point,
I'm going to have
to ask you to please
step off the forge floor.
- Thank you, Ben.
- Good fight.
- That was awesome.
- Thank you so much.
- Good job.
CALEB LEDFORD: Thank you all.
- Good job, Caleb.
Ben, that's it, man.
You are now 7 and
0 in this forge.
Congratulations, buddy.
Jeez Louise.
[applause]
Oh, my god, I just won
another competition.
I'm now 7 and 0.
This is phenomenal.
I'm almost kind
of starting to get
used to the winning this thing.
Among all your blades
that I've ever wielded,
I'd say this is the best one.
Thank you so much.
The only issue, now, of course,
is that every time I win,
I'm more, and more, and
more afraid of a loss.
HOST: The Ida sword.
[laughs] Oh, the Ida.
NARRATOR: The Ida sword used
by the Yoruba people of West
Africa features a double-edge,
leaf-shaped blade ideal
for harvesting
crops in the fields,
as well as inflicting lethal
slashes and stabs in battle.
This deadly weapon appeared in
season 4 of "Forged in Fire,"
where both smiths produced
ornate, Damascus patterns,
but one smith's mistake
during his quench
caused the sword to chip
during the strength test,
costing him the competition.
Your time starts now.
5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Great work.
Please put down your blades and
prepare yourselves for testing.
DOUG MARCAIDA: All
right, bladesmiths,
welcome to dynamic kill test.
To find out how lethal
your Ida swords are,
I'm going to cut through
this ballistics dummy
and pork loins.
You guys ready?
Let's do it.
CONTESTANT: All
right, let's do this.
[music playing]
[chopping sound]
All right, guys, the first
thing about this is when you
pick it up, it's
forward-heavy because you
have thicker grinds right here.
But when you swing
it, it's manageable.
I like the flare that you put
over there because it's really
giving me a nice
counterbalance, especially
when you're swinging
something that
has a forward weight to it.
Overall, it will kill.
[music playing]
[chopping sound]
All right, gentlemen,
when I pick up this blade,
I can feel the
distribution of the weight
be far more even compared
to gold's over here.
When I'm cutting this,
because of that distribution,
it's even a deeper chop
into this ballistics dummy.
Now, when I'm grabbing
on to the handle here,
actually, it feels good.
It's so forward, I can really
tell where the edge is.
Overall, it will kill.
[music playing]
DAVID BAKER: All
right, gentlemen,
it's time for our combined
strength and sharpness test--
the ammo crate chop
and foam dummy slice.
Gold anvil's up.
[music playing]
[chopping sound]
So right off, when you
pick up this weapon,
there's a lot of weight
up here in this blade.
But in that test, the blade
took a warp right there.
As far as the edges of the blade
go, they held up quite well.
But there's really no
getting around that bend.
[music playing]
[chopping sound]
All right, this thing
is a superior cutter.
Those cuts took
maybe half the effort
to get deeper into that target.
As far as the strength test
goes, it took no damage.
Nice piece.
GRADY POWELL: Well,
bladesmiths, in 8 hours,
you were both tasked
to build a very
difficult blade with an even
more difficult technique.
But in this competition, only
one of you can come out on top.
The winner of today's "Forged
in Fire" competition is--
[music playing]
Ben Abbott.
You are now 8 and 0, buddy.
Congratulations.
Brent, I'm going to have
to ask you to please
step off the forge floor.
I was able to do something
pretty incredible, I think,
in 8.
Hours but Ben's a
whole other level.
It looks like he took 4 days
on it like a normal challenge.
Unbelievable.
I'm a two-time loser.
Ben, Ben, Ben.
A current record of
8 and 0 in the forge.
How are you feeling?
I feel amazing.
I'm super excited.
Brent is such an amazing smith.
And to be able to pull
off a win against him--
I just feel absolutely amazing.
But here I am, still undefeated.
With any luck, I'll be able to
keep the streak alive for ever
and a day.
There's a lot of
smiths out there
that might want to take me down.
But I'm here.
I'm ready.
Bring it on.
HOST: The spatha.
NARRATOR: The spatha sword dates
back to third century Rome.
This cavalry weapon features
a straight, double-edged blade
that allows for deeper,
deadlier cuts and thrusts
than the shorter
gladius sword previously
used by the Roman soldiers.
First featured in season
7 of "Forged in Fire,"
two smiths impressed the judges
with their ornate versions
of this blade.
However, one smith's failure to
include one of the parameters--
a medial ridge--
cost him the competition.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Bladesmiths
welcome to the dynamic kill
test.
I'm going to deliver
some slashes and thrusts
on this pig carcass and try to
cut through these tatami mats.
The blue anvil is up first.
[chopping sound]
All right, gentlemen, first
up, when you're looking at this
handle here, because it's a
forward-weight on the sword,
there's no counterbalance
here that--
every time I'm swinging this--
the blade wants
to leave my hand.
But these cuts onto the
pig carcass are very deep.
But overall, this
weapon, it will kill.
The bar has been
set really high.
I just hope mine can match it.
[chopping sound]
[music playing]
DOUG MARCAIDA: All
right, gentlemen,
so the balance of the blade
is back toward the handle,
so it's easier to control.
The edges took no damage.
On the pig carcass,
the weight distribution
of slashing with this
actually cuts very deep.
Overall, this
weapon, it will kill.
All right, gentlemen,
it's time for our dynamic
strength and sharpness
test-- the clay
pot smash and fish slice.
This is all about the edge
retention of your blade,
how well they cut, and how
well they feel in my hand.
So gentlemen, it's
time to start.
[music playing]
[chopping sound]
All right, so it held
its edge, which is great.
The weight's not an issue other
than, once you finish a swing,
the recovery is a
little bit slower.
But it held up well.
Good job.
[chopping sound]
[music playing]
All right, so, right
off, when I pick
up the sword, what I feel more
than anything is the balance.
You want that balance
point right there.
The pattern is beautiful.
The edge held up really
well and cut well.
And though I love the attempt
at historical accuracy
in this handle, it would have
been nice to see a little bit
more finish work done on it.
Having said that, when
I put it in my hand,
it fits really nicely.
It's nicely done.
GRADY POWELL: Well,
bladesmiths, it comes
down to this final moment.
You both did a phenomenal job.
Judges agree, both your
blades tested almost evenly,
so it came down to the
very finest of details.
The stakes are really high.
Ben, if you win, you will remain
undefeated and go to a record
of 9 wins and 0 losses.
Our judges discussed
your blade, and they came
out with a final conclusion.
And the winner of today's
"Forged in Fire" competition
is--
[music playing]
--he has done it again--
Ben Abbott.
Congratulations.
Oh, my god.
- Congratulations.
- Oh, my god.
Nicholas,
unfortunately, your blade
didn't come out on top today.
You smoked the competition.
You did a phenomenal job here.
But unfortunately,
at this time, I'm
going to have to
ask you to please
step off the forge floor.
- Thank you guys very much.
- Thank you so much.
- See you, Nick.
- Nice job, man.
NICHOLAS COCHIOLO:
I did my best.
Ben came out on top.
Totally deserves the win.
Ben Abbott, we are running
out of fingers to count on.
You are the champion, again.
9 and 0.
Buddy, how do you feel?
I feel amazing.
So much of me has gone
into it blood-wise,
but I'm just super jealous
that they paid off.
I just became a "Forged
in Fire" champion again.
I am just elated.
This is probably one of the
best experiences of my life
to go through five competitions
and win all five of them
in a row.
DOUG MARCAIDA: The
blade, I'd say,
right now, that's
the most stunning
pattern that you've presented.
In each of these
competitions, I've learned
a little bit of somethings.
You have to learn
how to be fast.
how to be good.
You have to learn
how to be smart.
And I just feel like my skill
is getting better and better
as I go.
Where do you go from here?
Dave, you ready to compete?
Sign me up.
Oh, hell yes.
I'm currently 9 and 0.
I'm unbeaten.
If you think you got what
it takes, bring it on.
I'm ready.